located in madagascar is a forest unlike  any other because if you look closely  this forest is made of stone  [Music]  the singhi de bemeraja also known as  singi stone forest is made of limestone  which was once underwater some 200  million years ago  the rocks all feature distinct  razor-sharp formations created by  erosion from tropical rain which washed  away the softer stone the reserve is  around 230 square miles in size and the  stone towers rise 220 feet from the  ground  although this dramatic landscape appears  inhospitable to nature singi is home to  some very resilient wildlife including  numerous wild bird populations and 11  different species of lemur  the word singy is indigenous to the  malagasy language and aptly translates  to where one cannot walk barefoot  however while one cannot walk barefoot  the singi stone forest is accessible to  those wanting to see and climb the  forest in real life  [Music]  [Music]  you